[Music]
[Applause]
getting away from it all has long been
the very definition of a vacation
but for some the all they're talking
about now includes the
online world and the smartphones tablets
and
pcs that can so dominate our lives
vacation destinations have seen the need
and are now offering places of refuge
and relief
from our media obsessed lives
good morning good morning ariel and jeff
dufour
tried something a little out of the
ordinary on a recent getaway
the main thing i'd like to point out to
you is that miraval is a device-free
property
so you're more than welcome to use your
phone as much as you'd like in the room
itself
however in the public areas we do ask
you keep your phones on either airplane
mode or silent
disconnecting from their devices to
reconnect with themselves
and each other it's a good time to get
away before we have our second child
kind of block out all of the stress and
digital
anxieties of real life why do you think
it's important
that you take a break from that digital
connection i think it's important for
our relationship and
us specifically because even when we're
together at night after our son's gone
to bed we're
looking at her phone or she's answering
a work email or i'm doing the same
um so we may be together but we're not
always talking or communicating or
actually
you know together yeah we spend like
every night
together but i feel like we had more
conversation last night than
typical the couple stayed at miraval
berkshires
a one thousand dollar a night
all-inclusive resort
that promises to awaken your senses if
you can put your phone
to sleep so these animals are all about
stillness
and quiet jen leahy is miraval's animal
connection
specialist if you just do kind of like
the back of her head is
she's pretty oh it's so soft my job
is to provide opportunities for our
guests to have
first hand experiences with the more
than human world that we have here
mayor of all berkshires she helped jeff
dufour come face to face
with an owl named jules i do it you're
fine
an uncomfortable accomplishment given
his fear of birds
it is incredibly soft animals are
incredible teachers they live in the now
and they ask us to join them there and
if we want to
explore that learn from them be a part
of that
we need to be there in our full selves
with the guests that you've had here and
i'm thinking between
pre-pandemic and now have you seen a
shift
in some of this unplugging and some of
the connection with the animals
that you have here too oh absolutely
the level of disconnection many of us
have experienced over the past year
has had a huge impact the human discount
absolutely precisely
precisely and the isolation and
animals offer us this opportunity for
connection
not just with them but by being with
them
it's a doorway into ourselves miraval's
three properties
help guests find more balance in their
lives through mindful activities
perfect some people may have a robust
well-being practice they may practice
yoga they may do meditation
and others are coming to dip their toe
in simon marks the group director of spa
and well-being at miraval berkshires
well-being is what
i think a sense of living life fully
being authentic to yourself and feeling
all of the joys
and challenges that that we all confront
in our day and
yet feeling comfortable and feeling able
to cope with them no one is going to
stop stress
it's how we manage it and i think that's
ideally what we're trying to help people
do is
is to teach them what to pay attention
to and discover the beauty around them
and within them
while the mir of all experience comes
with a high price tag
marks says the company is finding ways
to make well-being more accessible
for all especially with demand for it
intensifying we'll be introducing a
digital mindfulness video series
to help support the pursuit of
mindfulness when you're not able to come
to mirrorball or perhaps before your
stay or after
for many americans coping during the
pandemic has been difficult
with the majority of employed adults in
the u.s working remotely
some get the feeling they're living at
work instead of working from home
suddenly work is like in every part of
your life like you
sleep in your work you have to be a lot
more intentional
about saying i want to step away from
work
dylan thuras is the co-founder of atlas
obscura
a company that curates unique
experiences and catalogs hidden wonders
like this pocket park in new york city
sometimes there's something like
a mile from your house he says people
are now looking for more meaningful
travel experiences
people are traveling again for sure but
it's mostly domestic right now
and people don't want to go back
to what they were doing before
necessarily like i don't think anyone's
super excited about going back to being
in a giant crowd of 50 000 people in
venice during high season right like
that's not what what people want
they're looking for stuff that's more
natural so maybe a little farther off
the beaten path
um and and yeah stuff that's that's
maybe closer to home
you can spend a fortune in escape but
you don't have to
to get what you want out of a vacation
that's right yeah one of the
one of the important ideas of atlas
obscura is it's not about
distance traveled or getting on a plane
or like stamps in a passport
it's really about being willing to kind
of trust
that you can find something incredible
almost anywhere you are
anywhere including in the middle of
nowhere
getaway is all about having more free
time and more balance in your life so
there's no wi-fi there's no tv
we really try to get you to do nothing
john's staff's company getaway
operates small cabins in remote areas
all over the country
guests can escape the noise of everyday
life
for about 120 dollars per night
everybody should have access to nature
and it's important for all of us to
carve time out of our daily life to sit
to think to reflect
to be with our loved ones and we hope
that can be getaway for so many folks
back at mir of all berkshires if the
dufours are any indication
an escape from reality may be just the
thing we all need
to cope with it what's been the overall
benefit of doing
this stay like this i think it's just a
reminder that like
this time together away from reality is
it's okay and we deserve it and
we need it to to get back to being the
best parents and people we can be
good lesson for all of us to know one
thing that was interesting that dylan
uh told me from alice obscura was that
you know people are doing a lot of
domestic
travel this year still in 2021 but
they've seen a
huge amount of international those
bigger trips already planned for in 2022
like people are saying okay i'll hold
back
and he said again you don't it's not how
far you go
it's what you do on that vacation which
helps you to unplug and reconnect
half the family time put the phones away
yeah i'm sold let's go
just have to do it let's go michelle's
pants
all right wonderful thank you